City are Premier League champions again
that's three titles in a row it's
dominance funded by Abu Dhabi with
around 2 billion pounds spent on the
squad in the 15 years of shake man
Saul's ownership but his City's spending
that castle Cloud over their Glory
they're currently contesting more than a
hundred alleged breaches a premier
league Financial rules charges covering
a decade of payments clubs can only
largely spend what they legitimately
earn but City Stand Accused of inflating
the value of sponsorships linked to Abu
Dhabi disguising income to channel more
cash into the club and not fully
disclosing payments to a manager City
who deny wrongdoing could be deducted
points or even expelled from the league
if found guilty the biggest disciplinary
case comes as City cements its status as
one of the League's greatest ever teams
and in the coming weeks they hope to
also be winning their FA Cup and
Champions League two to complete a
travel